today's gift video is a little different
from normal so be prepared for music
emoji and being told you're hot as Alex
from play the mind takes on some
translations Alex take it away your hard
and full movie where life will always be
a default rule you just choose a
conscious Maxim that's what alert so
summer change but the music's things the
same parity songs are a good example of
Carter factor and so are some
translations but as opposed to parodies
song translation gives a false
impression of remaining faithful to the
original
for instance what I just sang is part of
the English version of the French songs
Latvia holes by Edith Piaf the French
lyrics of what I sang are if there is a
sub X lot a lot of the songs on one
won't turn Chiba the meaning of these
words has nothing to do with what I just
sang as a matter of fact the whole
English version ends up becoming short
bilingual gender-neutral and subtle
directed to the loved ones which are
characteristics not present in the
original French version and this song
isn't the only case where this happens
when dealing with any song translation
there's a conflict between the meaning
of the lyrics and the way we found when
spoken if you were to translate a song
purely based on meaning you are end up
having lyrics with beats falling on
syllables which naturally don't receive
an accent when spoken so somewhere you
need to sacrifice meaning in order to
preserve good sound and who's to blame
for making strong translations so darn
complicated it's full knowledge e the
phonology of the language is like it's
musical DNA and it has a primordial
influence on how the melody of a song
gets written in a certain language even
the particular way a baby cries has to
do with how its mother speaks
there's two things to consider in
phonology the phonemes are the vowels
and consonants that make up speech and
the porosity of a language is the way
the phonemes are put together into
syllables words and sentences and their
information in order to convey meaning
it's the paucity of English that makes a
difference between saying hey you're hot
and saying hey you're hot but back to
music it's the phonological system of a
language which shapes the melody of a
song originally written in that language
and we're translating that song is the
language of a completely different
biological systems something is up
sounding bad for instance some languages
like Hindi or Italian are more favorable
to melismatic singing where you have
multiple notes sung over just a few
values here's an example in English that
was really consistent and the other
languages such as German or polish are
more favorable to syllabic singing where
you have one note per syllable Roy -
Scherzer is removed imposter of a CEO so
Israel began his own type setup therein
lies the crux of the matter setting the
text of a syllabic language to a
melismatic song or vice versa
sounds force artificial and fully aware
that no language is purely syllabic or
surely melismatic but I'm emphasizing
these extremes in order to drive my
point home a fan translation can either
sound good but the integrated meaning or
it can be actress but some that take
your pick but how important are some
translations nowadays well think of this
roughly 80 million people speak Korean
worldwide yes to this base the video on
YouTube with most views is the Korean
song Gangnam style with more than two
and a half billion views this means most
of the audience probably didn't
understand a word that was in some
go subscribe to play the mind for all
sorts of videos about music theory and
acoustics including one about the very
first mic drop next time in the last
guest video of the run we have something
in the ever popular genre of that thing
you're eating isn't what you think it is
see you then